International nationalism
that's what people were jokingly
referring to it as like the idea that
there was a movement of individuals to
strengthen their own countries and their
own borders and respect between
different countries to allow each to do
so so the media tried mocking the idea
but it was actually quite simple it
meant that someone from the UK was like
hey this is where I live we want to have
these rules that's totally cool that you
live over there and want to have those
rules and then we'll figure out how to
work together and everyone's like yeah
that sounds like a really great idea so
it's an international movement to
restore and strengthen National
boundaries yeah I think Libertarians
have the answer you hear comic Dave
Smith on this show and how based he is
decentralization like you just mentioned
yeah that's the answer to me
yeah they have the United States of
Mexico is already primed we've got the
United States of America we've got
Canada's basically a bunch of provinces
States uh China's a bunch of States like
we're we're really as long as the People
Want it we're prepped to create a
decentralized state across the planet